[Applause]
[Music]
when donald trump was sworn in as
president of the united states in 2017
we all had a pretty good idea of what
his relationship with the rest of the
world would be like
america first america
first
it was the defining slogan of his
campaign but four years have passed and
now the new president has announced a
change of strategy
america is back joe biden on twitter
wait a minute twitter
another president addicted to twitter no
don't worry this president isn't going
down the same path biden uses twitter to
give his speeches wider reach and for
such interesting things as wishing the
hmong ethnic group
all the best for the new year or
remembering a certain sikh holiday but
the really important question is what
exactly does biden mean when he says
that america
is back is it that under donald trump
america had disappeared obviously not
but surprisingly trump has been one of
the most pacifist u.s presidents
in history at least if we're talking
about war conflicts and interventions
you could say
he fits into the category of his bark is
worse than his bite in other words
people who threaten are not the most
dangerous because they limit themselves
to shouting and getting angry but rarely
take action
okay so trump let off steam from time to
time on twitter but when it came down to
it
what became of it well not much in iraq
and especially in afghanistan he has
been reducing the presence of u.s
troops to the point of considering a
complete withdrawal in 2021 in regards
to the islamic state perhaps his biggest
operation whilst in office as president
he limited himself to continuing what
was already underway
so in the end the most significant war
initiative of the 45th president of the
united states has been this one
america just attacked assad's forces for
the second time ever
vox so that's it we're talking about a
couple of bombing raids on syria as
punishment
to bashar al-assad for using chemical
weapons the rest have been one-off
actions
so-called surgical operations like when
special forces took out the caliph
al-baghdadi of the islamic state
or when a drone attacked killed the
iranian general suleimani and so on and
so forth basically
this has been the list of warlike
actions undertaken by donald trump
in this sense his term has been quite
peaceful no one will be able to say
donald trump started this or that war
although the truth is that the u.s
military did not seem to have the energy
for more and more conflicts
[Music]
in any case if we dig a little deeper we
soon realized that president trump's
foreign policy has been an absolute
break with a doctrine that had dominated
all u.s actions internationally since
world war ii the doctrine
packs americana keep this term in mind
yes over time the enemy has changed from
communism to
islamic fundamentalism but maintaining
the pax americana was the common
denominator behind the korean war
vietnam afghanistan and iraq in fact it
is what has been behind
each and every one of the united states
wars sure
we're talking about pax americana but we
also talk about numerous military
interventions
in fact this doctrine has received a lot
of criticism it has even been ridiculed
with memes like this one
so the questions that come up for this
video are how effective were trump's
foreign policy and his america first
slogan will biden's presidency be a
return to the traditional doctrine of
pax americana today on visualpolitik we
are going to answer these questions but
first
let's take a look at a little bit of
[Music]
history
americana
[Music]
now if i were to tell you that germany
has nuclear bombs what would you say
i'm sure many of you are wondering how
on earth this could be possible because
germany didn't even have an army after
world war ii what if whoever succeeds
merkel goes crazy and suddenly proclaims
i don't know the fourth reich well hold
on a minute friends because
i've set a little trap for you
[Music]
it turns out there are nuclear bombs on
german soil and if any other country
let's say for example russia should
happen to attack germany then a similar
response could be given however the
nuclear bombs in germany do not belong
to germany but
are on one of the military bases that
the united states has in this country
this is provided for in nato's defense
strategy remember that the atlantic
treaty is a system of collective defense
among its members that came out after
world war
ii yet another instrument of the pax
americana
but where did it all start well
basically at the end of world war ii the
united states was the greatest global
superpower at the time the country
accounted for almost 50 percent of the
world's gdp the dollar had displaced the
pound sterling as the main reserve
currency of the international economic
system and militarily no one could
dispute its air
and naval power what's more for a number
of years it remained dominant due to the
fact that it was the only country with
nuclear weapons
so back in washington in 1945 they did
their math
and they realized that what was in their
best interest was a peaceful world but
how could they achieve this well first
of all by intervening in the enemy
countries so that they would abandon
their authoritarian regimes and develop
democracies instead their second
interest was fundamentally
trait the us dream was that the entire
western bloc would trade with each other
completely independently of the
communist countries under soviet
influence
according to washington this way if the
major powers linked their economies
through trade they would be much less
tempted to declare war on their
neighbours
and this is precisely another one of the
pillars of pax americana
if goods don't cross borders soldiers
will attributed to frederick bastiat
eventually goods crossed borders and
capitalist countries prospered
but my friends in order for goods to
cross borders without problems security
was needed for example
in order for an oil tanker to leave the
ports of saudi arabia
and reach the u.s coast it must not be
intercepted by another country's fleet
or raided by the modern version of
pirate ships and in the midst of the
cold war the united states was convinced
that guaranteeing all this transit of
goods would be the best way to achieve
peace and prosperity
was the week that changed the world
that is precisely why the united states
is one of the few countries in the world
that has military bases in other
countries
to ensure that its own interests are
safe such as the security
of global shipping lanes and take note
because we are not talking about one or
two dusty bases out there we
are talking about around 800 military
bases spread all over the planet
bases that have been fundamental in
preventing the us's allies from being
victims of attacks
and that that is also pax americana but
of course having said that i'm sure more
than one of you will be thinking
how can a country allow the united
states to send soldiers to its territory
in times of peace
after all it's an intrusion on its
sovereignty right
[Music]
well all this my friends has been
possible thanks to multilateralism we
are talking about
all kinds of commercial and military
alliances between different countries
that is where nato fits in and this
agreement has already been expanded to
countries of eastern europe
the point is that at the end of the day
all military alliances in which
washington participates
consists of pretty much the same
elements
[Music]
whether declared or not the objective of
these military alliances is for the
world's largest army that of the united
states to guarantee protection in the
event of an attack
by a third country of course military
protection always requires the same
thing
military bases on the territory so
that's why there are nuclear weapons on
german soil and that's why the us5 fleet
is in bahrain the 6th fleet
in italy and the 7th fleet in japan it
also explains why there are nearly 30
000 u.s troops in south korea despite
trump's photo frenzy with kim jong-un
and of course given the us's massive
global presence
the real question is so has this pax
americana thing worked it certainly did
for a long time and the proof is
globalization in fact you could say that
the pax americana reached its peak 30
years ago when the berlin wall fell and
the communist bloc disintegrated at that
time friends the world was trading in
harmony and the united states had become
the world's policeman
however as of 2001 this model began to
[Applause]
fail
the first sign came when a man who had
been trained by the cia to fight the
soviets
osama bin laden attacked the united
states with the september 11 terrorist
attacks
then there were wars in afghanistan and
iraq two disasters where many u.s
soldiers lost their lives and where
contrary to what happened with germany
and japan the united states has been
unable to turn these countries into
prosperous nations and their situations
have not only not improved but become
considerably worse and that explains why
under the united states under obama
began to back away from its role as the
world's policeman for example it did not
intervene in the syrian civil war and
looked the other way when russia invaded
crimea so what obama did was to deepen
the pax americana not from a military
point of view but from a strictly
commercial one
what the obama administration did was to
put on track
several trade agreements with large
lists of countries this was the case
with the ttip
a proposed agreement with the european
union and the trans-pacific partnership
with 11 countries in the americas
asia and oceana an agreement that was to
create the largest free trade zone on
the planet
a zone that would gradually end up
imposing north american trade rules in
other words obama's legacy was the
magnum opus of trade multilateralism but
then along came trump
[Music]
america first america alone
america first sure let's see donald
trump as the president of the united
states
is not going to say zimbabwe first the
point is that with america first what
trump was telling us is that the united
states was going to do away with the
multilateralism that it had developed
since world war
ii and it must be said that president
trump was not fooling anyone
he had already put forward this idea in
the republican primary debates
the tpp is a horrible deal
it is a deal that is going to lead to
nothing but trouble
[Music]
and not only did he criticize the
trans-pacific partnership the same
happened with ttip and remember
that even the nafta deal was
renegotiated after being up and running
for 25 years
in order to infuse it with a little bit
of protectionism but some may be
wondering why trump has been so critical
of these trade agreements well my
friends
let's say that the magnate's point of
view is that it is not in the united
states interest
to enter into multilateral agreements
during his time in the white house trump
has proven to be a convinced
protectionist
it's true that free trade the united
states may go hand in hand with unfair
competition capable of destroying jobs
and businesses he also believed that
what the united states would have to do
is to close trade agreements country by
country because then
being the most powerful economic and
military power in the world the us could
impose its rules
naturally the other side would accept
his conditions because they would be
crazy to be left
out of a trade agreement with the united
states
that is precisely why the first thing
trump did as president was to nullify
those agreements
but his foreign policy didn't stop there
[Music]
he also took a very tough position on
nato because of course depending on how
you look at it nato can be a blessing or
a black hole
for the united states it can be an
instrument that makes you the priority
ally
of european countries with all that that
implies at the economic level or in
terms of influence but it can also be a
bottomless pit as far as spending goes
that is why trump did not hesitate to
crack the whip
europe has to pay their fair share for
military protection
the european union for many years has
taken advantage of us on trade
and then they don't live up to their
military commitment through nato things
must change fast
another change in u.s foreign policy can
be seen in the middle east
president trump's policy there has been
very simple leave everything in the
hands of saudi arabia the united arab
emirates and
israel and if in doubt walk away obama's
dream executed to perfection well that
and making sure to keep israel and saudi
arabia sweet at all gusts you only have
to remember
the gestures that saudi arabia has made
to this country it supported them in
their confrontation with qatar despite
the latter being a close ally
this same country was the destination of
trump's first official trip where he
performed the infamous little dance of
the sword
and not only that trump has made two
other very important gestures with the
saudis
the first ending obama's reproachment
with iran and the nuclear pact
the second closing a deal to sell the
saudis 100 billion dollars worth of
weapons
and that being said has trump had to do
anything in return well yes
and some pretty nasty stuff things like
this trump reportedly says he protected
saudi crown prince after khashoggi
murder i saved his
according to bob woodward's upcoming
book trump was willing to overlook jamal
khashoggi's murder as long as saudi
arabia kept the money flowing which
raises the question
has this helped or not well the
conclusion is that trump has had at
least some failures here but also some
successes of course they have not come
cheap because in addition to having to
turn a blind eye to the murder of
khashoggi by selling arms to saudi
arabia the u.s became an accomplice in
the war in yemen where serious
violations of human rights are being
committed
in summary on the one hand trump is
leaving an unstable situation in the
middle east due to the tensions between
saudi arabia and the emirates with qatar
and iran what's more
washington has also had to intervene
when saudi and emirati oil tankers have
been attacked in the strait of hamuz nor
can we forget the betrayal of the us
allies in iraqi kurdistan but on the
other hand the peace agreement between
israel and the arab countries was a
historic event
i guess we have to give credit where
credit's due finally there is the change
of attitude of the united states towards
china what is happening is that trump
instead of organizing a military
alliance against the asian giant has
instead
tried to use the power of the dollar
with the trade war which we have already
covered on visualpolitik numerous times
and that well has been a huge failure it
has achieved nothing it has harmed u.s
interests and to top it off
washington has lost a very important
bargaining chip
perhaps without the trade war we would
never have seen the takeover of hong
kong let me explain let's say that
washington
always played the sanctions card and
when they finally used it the chinese
realized that
it was not so much a big deal or at
least that they were willing to take the
hit until there was an administration
more open to dialogue in addition to the
fall of hong kong
washington has not managed to curb a
very aggressive chinese expansionist
policy there is the case of taiwan which
continues to be the victim of ongoing
threats but the biggest failure by far
of
trump's america first policy has just
occurred china signs huge
asia-pacific trade deal with 14
countries yes as you can see its
partners in this agreement
are the 10 countries of the association
of southeast asian nations along with
another four south korea japan australia
and new zealand
four countries that have traditionally
been the main allies of the united
states
in the region of course it is here that
trump's failure becomes evident because
u.s allies have continued to bet on
multilateralism even though the white
house was
no longer showing interest in
participating in that whole strategy
conclusion china has more and more
influence at the international level and
also
more weight in international
institutions for example the who when
washington steps back
beijing steps forward to fill the vacuum
anyway as you can see beyond the
so-called abraham agreements between
israel and the arab countries the
successes of the american first strategy
are conspicuous by their absence
but it did not declare any wars and that
is very good but now the question is
what will biden do when he gets to the
white house well let's take a look at
that right now
it is the key you built up wealth that's
how
middle class folks make it they build up
well it tells everything from
early education it's about accumulating
wealth
we got to change that it's about
accumulating wealth
the american comeback
joe biden is the first u.s president in
the last 30 years with deep foreign
policy experience he spent 34 years as a
member of the senate
foreign affairs committee and then there
are his eight years as obama's vice
president
he is a convinced believer in
multilateralism and has very clear ideas
precisely for this reason he has
refrained from doing what obama did when
he plays two political stars like
hillary clinton and john kerry at the
head of state department to represent
the united states abroad in contrast
biden has chosen his right-hand man of
20 years anthony blinken and my late
stepfather
samuel pizarro he was one of 900
children in his school in bialystok
poland but the only one
to survive the holocaust after four
years in concentration camps
at the end of the war he made a break
from a death march into the woods in
bavaria
from his hiding place he heard a deep
rumbling sound
it was a tank but instead of the iron
cross he saw painted on its side
a five-pointed white star he ran to the
tank
the hatch opened an african-american gi
looked down
at he got down on his knees and said the
only three words that he knew in english
that his mother taught him
before the war god bless america
that's who we are that's what america
represents to the world
and he has entrusted him with one
mission above all others to regain the
trust of allies
scorned by donald trump the president
this
president trump has changed the
landscape it's become
america first which meant america alone
we find ourselves in a position where
our alliances are being frayed
of course the real question is whether
he is in time to make up the ground lost
by the 45th president of the united
states
of course in the case of the great
asia-pacific trade agreement the
complication is that once china has
entered the united states will find
difficult to impose its terms
as for the approach biden will take with
the asian giant his idea is for the
united states to lead the west when they
sit down to negotiate with beijing biden
and blinken believe that with the
support of its allies washington can say
to beijing hey china here's 60
of the world's gdp not just the 25
percent that the united states represent
and we agree that you can't do this they
believe this will make it easier for
china to show more respect for the rules
of the international economic game such
as intellectual property rights or
unfair competition
through state support for private
companies such as huawei in any case
even if trump's departure means that the
trade war to china does not escalate
this does not mean that tariffs will be
withdrawn immediately the us no longer
views china in the same light
it did 10 years ago
[Music]
the democratic party came to believe
that china's economic reforms would
eventually bring political reform it is
true that since the time of deng
xiaoping few countries have benefited as
much from the pax americana because
china
has taken advantage of the political
stability of the far east
and the global trade networks already
used by japan and the asian tigers but
as far as political reforms go they seem
more distance than ever
what will change radically is the
position of the united states in
international institutions
in fact we already know two of his
decisions on the one hand biden plans to
stop the us exit from the world health
organization
scheduled for july 2021 and on the other
hand he also wants to bring the united
states back into the fight against
climate change by re-signing the paris
agreement you know that the democrats
ran their presidential campaign with the
ambitious
environmental plan to decarbonize the
economy in the medium term these may be
his first foreign policy measures so now
the question is over to you what do you
expect from president biden in
international affairs do you think the
america first years have been a mistake
will pax americana return what's more
will we see bombings on cnn again leave
your answers down in the comments so i
really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there